Efe o sabah balkonda, annesinin yanındaydı.
Elindeki bardakta kesilmiş bir gül dalı duruyordu.
Dalın alt ucundan incecik beyaz kökler çıkmıştı.
Efe bardağa iyice yaklaştı.
Annesi bu dalı toprağa dikeceklerini söyledi.
Birkaç ay sonra, yepyeni bir gül olacaktı.
Efe şaşırdı.
Bu dalın ne annesi vardı, ne babası.
Peki nasıl yeni bir canlı oluyordu?
Sonra çevresine baktı.
Bahçedeki kedi, gökteki kuş, taşın çatlağındaki filiz.
Hepsi çoğalıyordu.
Bunun bir adı vardı.
Üreme.
Efe fendefterini açtı.
İlk sayfada iki büyük yol çizilmişti.
Eşeysiz üreme ve eşeğili üreme.
Önce eşeysiz üreme.
Burada anne baba gibi iki ayrı cinsiyet yoktu.
Üreme hücresi de yoktu.
Ortada tek bir atacanlı vardı.
Hepsi bu.
Ondan oluşan yeni canlı, atasının birebir aynısıydı.
Tıpkı fotokopi makinesinden çıkmış gibi.
Eşeysiz üremenin dört ana çeşidi vardı.
Efe birincisinden başladı.
Birincisi bölünerek üremeydi.
En basit ve en hızlı olanı.
Efe mikroskoba eğildi.
Camın üstünde küçücük bir amip duruyordu.
Amip tam ortadan ikiye ayrıldı.
Bir canlıdan iki canlı olmuştu.
Ölena, paramesyum ve bakteriler de böyle çoğalırdı.
Tam ortadan ikiye bölünerek.
Efe saydı.
Bir, iki, dört, sekiz.
Bölünerek üreme şaşırtıcı derecede hızlıydı.
İkincisi tomucuklanmaydı.
Bu kez atacanlı ikiye ayrılmıyordu.
Vücudunun bir yerinde küçük bir çıkıntı oluşuyordu.
Buna tomucuk deniyordu.
Efe hidranın göldesindeki minik çıkıntıya baktı.
Tomucuk gün geçtikçe büyüyordu.
Büyüyen tomucuk ana canlıdan ayrıldı ve kendi başına yeni bir canlı oldu.
Deniz anası, hidra ve maya mantarları işte böyle çoğalırdı.
Üçüncüsü, regenerasyondu.
Efenin en havalı bulduğu yöntem buydu.
Canlıdan kopan bir parça eksik kalan yerlerini kendi kendine tamamlıyordu.
Deniz yıldızından kopan tek bir kol yavaş yavaş yepyeni bir deniz yıldızına dönüştü.
Toprak solucanı ikiye ayrıldığında da parçalarından yeni solucanlar oluşabiliyordu.
Ama burada bir tuzak vardı.
Efe bunu defterine kırmızı kalemle yazdı.
Kertenkele'nin kopan kuyruğu yeniden uzar, evet.
Ama bu sadece bir yenilenmedir.
Ortaya yeni bir kertenkele çıkmaz.
Yani bu üreme değildir.
Dördüncüsü, vejetatif üremeydi.
Bu yöntem yalnızca bitkilere özeldi.
Efe mutfaktaki patatesi eline aldı.
Üstünde küçük gözler filizlenmişti.
Patatesin gözlenmesi yeni bir patates bitkisinin başlangıcıydı.
Çileğin toprak üstünde uzayan gövdesi, değdiği yerde kök salıp yeni çilek veriyordu.
Ve Efe sabah gördüğü gül dalını hatırladı.
Toprağa dikilen o dal, yeni bir gül tutuyordu.
Dört yöntemde aynı kapıya çıkıyordu.
Tek ata üreme hücresi yok.
Birebir aynı yeni canlı.
Sonra Efe defterindeki ikinci yola geçti.
Eşeğili üreme.
Burada işin içine iki farklı cinsiyet giriyordu.
Dişi ve erkek.
Dişinin üreme hücresine yumurta, erkeğin üreme hücresine sperm deniyordu.
Yumurtayla sperm birleşti.
Bu olayın adı dörlenmeydi.
Dörlenme sonucu oluşan o tek hücreye zigot deniyordu.
Zigot bölündü, büyüdü, gelişti ve yeni bir birey oluşturdu.
Efe kedisinin sepetine baktı.
İçinde üç yavru uyuyordu.
Üçü de annelerine benziyordu ama hiçbiri onun birebir aynısı değildi.
Hatta üç yavru birbirinden de farklıydı.
İşte eşeğili üremenin en önemli özelliği buydu.
Çeşitlilik.
Efe aynaya baktı.
Annesine de babasına da benziyordu.
Ama tıp atıp ikisi de değildi.
İnsanlar, kediler, köpekler, kuşlar ve çiçekli bitkiler,
hepsi eşeğili üreme ile çoğalırdı.
Efe defterin son sayfasına iki sütunlu bir tablo çizdi.
Atacanlı sayısı.
Eşeğisiz üreme de tek ata.
Eşeğili üreme de dişi ve erkek.
Yani iki ata.
Üreme hücresi.
Eşeğisiz üreme de yok.
Eşeğili üreme de var.
Sperm ve yumurta.
Çeşitlilik.
Eşeğisiz üreme de yok.
Tıpkı fotokopi gibi.
Eşeğili üreme de var.
Her yavru farklı.
Efe balkona döndü.
Güldalı bardakta.
Yavrular sepette.
Kuş daldaydı.
Artık çevresine baktığında hangisinin nasıl çoğaldığını biliyordu.
Merakla kalın.
Bilimle kalın.